ses petits amis
j'ai le goût bas qui va voir un petit
peu amusante aaa
alors il est bien ce jeu mais c'est vrai
qu'il a des gros doigts
on va devoir
on a fait signe à chrome os de cameo
dans cette émission
alors comme on dit dans le cinéma
oh
sans transition vient d'apprendre marcus
célèbres icônes du jeu vidéo a été
retrouvé chez lui avec et de couper la
voie douloureux et b messieurs tout ça
avait commencé il ya des semaines pour
le prochain test seb avait commencé
avant moi à jouer au jeu et quelque
chose me disais que ce je commençais à
le changer
ouais j'en étais sur fond noir
il avait changé il tenait sa perche de
la main gauche alors qu'il était
droitier peu de temps après il avait
disparu jamais fouillé ses affaires pour
finalement retrouver les coupables
oracle dit moi tout ce que tu sais il
n'y avait qu'une seule solution si je
voulais retrouver saine
il fallait que je comprenne ce qu'il
avait changé batman forever sorti en
1995 développé par probe les mêmes que
pour le batman et robin de la
playstation qui apparemment aujourd'hui
vous propose de faire vos devoirs ou de
vous vendre des mangas sexy comme quoi
ya une justice
bref si je devais vous parlez de batman
forever en deux mots je dirais
ta gueule le stagiaire ta gueule non
sérieusement ce film était est mauvais
alors oui peut-être que jim carrey sauve
le film des trains complets trop non
c'était nul
réveillez vous la nullité de ce film
elle est atténuée parce que le comparent
toujours à batman et robin qui lui est
vraiment aussi agréable à regarder qu'un
chat écrasé sur lequel honorem famille
mais ça n'en reste pas moins un beau
melting n'a été créé que pour vendre des
jouets batman c'était nul
alors beaucoup d'entre nous l'ont aimé
ce film mais c'est parce qu'on était
enfant et les enfants c'est con alors
après je sais pas peut-être que le jeu
sera mien peut-être que ce sera une
bonne surprise et a vu c'est le même
moteur que mortal kombat ah oui
effectivement ça rappelle vaguement
quelque chose ces animations ce jeu
c'est mortal kombat c'est vraiment
mortal kombat regarde y'a même un mode
baston ce genre ils se sont même pas
caché que c'était mortal kombat quoi bon
alors à la limite on va dire que c'est
un choix artistique
mais bon vous savez il ya des artistes
de merde aussi un par exemple j'ai pas
le choix artistique de mettre une bande
noire là qui fait un tir de la taille de
l'écran c'est pour faire quoi c'est pour
faire tard qu attendait regarder on peut
faire encore plus dark l'afp avait vu où
c'est encore plus dark c'est un connard
et ça aussi la com en effet que le cac
vient de brut 1,2 des cordes maire
devant personne des chapelets veuillez
m'excuser je suis désolé j'ai perdu mon
sang-froid devant cet éternel problème
des décors en premier plan qui t'empêche
de voir le jeu
donc voila mais pour exprimer ce que je
ressens j'ai composé une petite chanson
des cordes berceau circulent et je te
dis moi je dans le coupé pas et même pas
le refrain encore la peau bref alors
ergonomie et l'étude scientifique de la
relation entre l'homme et ses moyens et
l'application de ses connaissances à la
conception de systèmes qui puisse être
utilisée par le plus grand nombre
grosse merde suire l'ergonomie ça
s'applique à tout ça s'applique aux jeux
vidéo ça s'applique à la vie de tous les
jours
les mecs ils ont inventé je sais pas moi
les voitures il en famille les boutons
au hasard dessus un char pour démarrer
le contact font tourner deux fois le
volant à droite une fois à gauche à une
fois le klaxon mais la silla ils ont
fait les trucs complètement au hasard
les contrôles de ce jeu ils ont été
placés de manière totalement aléatoire
sur la manette
je veux dire déjà un truc simple comment
on monte à ce [ __ ] d'état je vois bien
qu'il ya un trou là j'ai tout trouvé
complètement par hasard la touche du
grappin qui est sûr c'est l'ex qui est
déjà une aberration ans oise ne devrait
pas y avoir une touche utiles sur select
mais là pourquoi j'arrive pas à monter à
ce [ __ ] des tâches pourquoi je sais
quoi que j'essaye sa fille comme ça oui
j'en à valence
et nous nous valons
est un baiser on avait
ok alors j'ai trouvé pour monter ses
select plus haut mais attention il faut
être exactement au pixel près au centre
du trou juste en dessous sinon ça ne
marche pas et ensuite il faut réellement
appuyé sur select et ensuite sion ok
parce que si tu fais select plus haut en
même temps ça ne marche pas c'est un peu
pareil pour les autres manip pour
descendre ses airs et bah pourquoi air
pourquoi je veux dire pourquoi pas deux
fois bas ou pourquoi pas select plus bas
vu qu'ils ont décidé de [ __ ] le bouton
pour monter sur select alors pourquoi
pas mettre des boutons pour descendre
sur select aussi pourquoi ils font
n'importe quoi
je parlerai même pas des items oui vous
savez là ces trucs que vous choisissez
en début de niveau et donc vous n'avez
pas la moindre idée de ce que ça peut
être je veux dire qu'est ce que je
choisis d'après vous est-ce que je
prends le bas de biche et le pistolet à
eau ou le truc qui brille type sans
speed 60 white 10 c'est quoi ces stats
haoues truc qu'il a un score de vitesse
de 45 pour une impédance de seulement 71
et ça pèse que 30
mais ça sert à quoi en fait non est ce
que je vous ai dit qu'il a quatre et ont
embêtés serre
c'est incroyable même sur le livret
c'est pas indiquée à quoi servent les
armes
genre le globe sonic ses world et attend
[ __ ] cette icône je comprends pas
qu'ils ont tout mélangé dans le livre et
ça correspond absolument pas ce qu'il ya
dans le jeu et mon dieu comme les
indications qu'on a appuyé plusieurs
fois de suite sur y tout en maintenant
le bouton de tir gauche enfoncée dans le
bouton 2
le bouton de tir gauche c'est existe pas
même le livret a pitié nous regardez
donc la dernière phrase qui parle du
dernier niveau et qui conclut la notice
persévérer c'est bientôt fini
merci ça donne envie d'y jouer vraiment
enfin bon alors j'ai pas vraiment poussé
le jeu plus loin que les deux ou trois
premiers niveaux s est déjà vraiment à
cette durée assez nul comme ça alors
entre les passages pour monter qui sont
cachés les passages où tu arrive devant
un mur tout simplement est arriv eyharts
tient devant toi ya un mur c'est tout et
en fait tu te rends compte qu'il fallait
juste descendre comme ça au milieu de
2,2 de rien pour avancer dans le niveau
t il face à travers le sol comme s'il
passait d'une case de bd à l'autre mais
mon petit chouchou mois que même si les
passages où tu arrives dans un tableau
du tube tous les ennemis après tu
cherches la sortie pendant 30 minutes en
essayant temps grappin sur chaque
centimètre carré de merde du tableau en
te disant que la solution sera forcément
à être une merde comme ça que au bout de
vingt minutes à faire ça tu es tellement
désespérée que tu commences à essayer
toutes les combinaisons possibles au
monde sur ta manette et que finalement
tu te rends compte que ce coup ci ils
ont décidé qu'il fallait juste retourner
à la porte d'entrée pour continuer
[ __ ] de merde c'est batman de med
c'est ridicule iep il peut pas avoir une
minimale qui lui indique où aller avec
toute la technologie de fou qu'il a il
est maintenant qu abraham lavaur google
maps sur son téléphone
le batman est le meilleur détective du
monde il battait super méchant et il
milliardaire dans sa vie son seul
problème c'est qu'il n'a pas le sens de
l'orientation
il va découvrir que de pas par le sens
de l'orientation
c'est pas facile pas demain n'est perdu
un film pour toute la famille bon alors
niveau variété d'ennemis ça va des
prisonniers d'arkham jusqu'au chanteur
du groupe partenaire particulier donc
l'éventail est assez large et d'ailleurs
fait intéressant à chaque ennemi possède
un nom différent à beaubourg c'est vrai
moi j'aurais préféré qu'ils passent un
peu moins de temps à trouver des noms
aux mecs du genre anglophile riff raff
creditor est un peu plus à bosser sur le
jeu d'ailleurs autre truc ce jeu on peut
y jouer à deux en même temps il ya un
qui prend batman et l'autre qui prend
robin c'est chouette non oui à nadal non
une balançoire c'est vrai que c'est
marrant batman et après moi je pense que
vous savez comment ça finit 1 to jeu
encore up où on peut se taper dessus
entre amis ça va jamais bien loin
surtout qu'ici le jeu est en cure de
descent profondeur et donc tu finit
forcément par taper ton pote en voulant
essayer de taper l'ennemi oracle j'ai
fini d'analyser les premiers jeux je
t'apprends les données aura deux
arobases libertysurf.fr taux minuscule
je pense ce qu'on veut
vous êtes en 2003 vous avez une gamecube
à quel jeu vidéo de super héros aimeriez
vous jouer à batman le meilleur effectif
du monde armé de tous ces super gadget
un procès super vilains à superman
l'homme d'acier invincible qui volent
aussi puissant qu'un dieu à green
lantern qui peut tout créé par la force
de la volonté de l'esprit à flash
l'homme le plus rapide du monde
à travers la matière à brotherhood qui
est mode ou aquaman qui parle aux
poissons et à qui il manque un bras donc
comme une sortie en 2003 alors c'est pas
le seul mauvais jeu de super héros dc
connaît sur gamecube
on a notamment aussi catwoman adapté du
film de pitof et dont la finalité du jeu
se limite juste finalement avoir à lever
rire ou les du cul en 3d alors aquaman
qu'est ce que ça donne et bien jetons
nous à l'eau et jeanne mance sur l'eau
tout ça allez on commence le jeu autant
le menu est faible le bloc comme dans
l'eau c'est rigolo
donc le jeu commence par une cinématique
absolument dégueulasse
[ __ ] c'est même pas une cinématique
c'est des captures d'écran du jeu attend
ça aucun sens
soit tu fais une scène cinématique avec
le moteur du jeu mais alors dans ce cas
là tu fais un truc qui bouge toi tu fais
des illustrations fixes qui sont jolies
mais tu les fais en dessin tu fais pas
juste des captures d'écran du jeu
saint-affrique ça a été fait par un
amateur ça là on dirait qu'ils ont
essayé de faire un truc un peu style
comics mais attendez regardez un comics
ça ressemble à ça il ya des perspectives
il ya des trucs joly qui se chevauchent
il ya un truc en plein écran là on
dirait storyboard de merde à la jarre
l'exercice que tu rends en option cinéma
au bac champ contre champ champ contre
champ et surtout ce qui est terrible
c'est que aquaman dans ces espèces
d'intro là il a une seule tête et quand
tu l'as remarqué après c'est fini tu ne
vois plus que ça
mais c'est bizarre ça ne semble pas être
la stratégie habituelle de blackmont
table pourquoi nous attaquent crée-t-il
[Musique]
il refuse de parler eux
bon bref alors pour aborder le jeu en
lui-même c'est un mauvais jeu parce que
c'est juste nul
les missions sont absolument tout les
mêmes à l'exception des phases en
vaisseau qui elles sont légèrement
différentes
pour le reste c'est simplement on suit
tout le temps la flèche ça nous amène
automatiquement vers les hommes crap qui
sont absolument les seuls ennemis qu'on
croisera dans le jeu le combat se
déclenche automatiquement à quoi mène sa
ligne automatiquement en mode combat par
boom combat suivant et ainsi de suite
paradoxalement ce jeu il avait du
potentiel sans déconner les combats sous
l'eau ça aurait pu être un truc très
sympa c'est dommage que la totalité du
budget soit parti dans l'animation des
cheveux de aquaman [ __ ] alors le jeu
est une chaussure
mais attention l'animation des cheveux
c'est c'est négatif on fait fausse piste
les résultats de l'impédance ne
correspondent pas ce n'est pas ce jeu
qui a rendu ces poux
samus mon petit canard on est perdu mais
s'ils meurent tremblay ont fait savoir
ce que j'ai dit à mon petit coeur et je
vais t'aider à voir ce que j'ai raté mes
parents sont morts un canard les a
mangés
c'était un gros cadart c'est un oiseau
c'est un avion non c'est pas bien c'est
un oiseau en fait le lot à merci
[Musique]
superman 64 vous le vouliez vous l'avez
c'est parti alors c'est un jeu édité par
titus qui comme je l'avais déjà dit fait
partie du gang des animaux français
maléfique avec le tattoo d'infogrames
alors déjà ce jeu il commence très bien
déjà rien quand tu laisses tourner la
démo c'est à dire le truc qui se lance
automatiquement quand tu fais rien sur
la page d'accueil du jeu elle bug la
démo bug fin tu le crois ça au bout d'un
moment la démo arrête de faire ce
qu'elle est censée faire elle arrête de
suivre le jeu et commence à faire
n'importe quoi
e ce superman doyen le mur bon bref
alors si ce jeu est souvent cité comme
étant le deuxième pire jeu de tous les
temps après haïti sur atari 2600 il ya
bien une raison
et honnêtement je ne sais pas du tout
par où commencer e
le jeu est divisé en deux parties à les
parties chantées nul et les parties
chiante et horrible et c'est pas celle
là qu'on va commencer évidemment c'est
difficile de vous faire comprendre à
quel degré quasi divin les contrôles de
ce jeu sont mauvais surtout avec cette
horrible manette analogique de la n64 ce
qu'il y en ait une en main ça vous coûte
de quoi je parle
ce jeu même après y avoir joué des
heures mais des oeuvres réellement vous
n'arriverez jamais à faire ce que vous
avez envie de faire même si vous
connaissez tous les boutons ne touche
les combinés de l'art rien vous
n'arriverez jamais à faire ce que vous
voulez faire la machine à perdre
oui superman ya pas de temps à perdre
alors explique moi pourquoi est ce que
dans ce jeu on passe notre temps à faire
des détours de merde
loïs lane je vais te sauver non il se
laisse je veux te sommet en slalom
leslie djhone tout le monde doutait mais
pourquoi fait je n'imagine âge de batman
avec ce système
[Musique]
sérieusement mais comment ils ont réussi
à rendre les contres merde de ce jeu
aussi nul c'est pas vrai ramé passe pas
au dessus les concentrations plus que
trois de plus que le dernier le dernier
oui oui [ __ ] je peux souffler une
seconde lille je fais quoi je peux je
vais où je call cac
qu'est ce que je fais comment comme
intra bas sous la voiture
comanche et la voiture truc ça marche et
ça a marché
ce jeu il est absolument aucun sens et
tout ça pour quoi
pour encore des cerceaux non non non je
vas te faire [ __ ] le jeu va te faire
[ __ ]
vous savez pourquoi en plus parce que
ils ont mis le bouton pour recommencer
du check point sur un an et le bouton
pour recommencer du début sur start
étant l'énervement je peux dire que vous
allez vous trompez y appuyer sur start
the back et deux fois
quel bonheur de pouvoir recommencer du
tout début pour profiter de l'élégance
de superman quand ils volent avec la
grâce de vieux troncs d'arbres là il ya
aussi des options dans ce jeu mais bon
dieu mais sérieux c'est quoi ça est ce
que quelqu'un peut me dire à quoi ça
sert d'avoir une option pour avoir le
jeu en tout petit vraiment je veux pas
tomber dans le délire habituel des
développeurs qui fument des joints à la
kryptonite nella expliquez moi
bon bref après quelques heures de jeu
vous connaissez par coeur le nouveau la
deuxième série d'anneaux et vous devriez
serra l'a passée et là rebelote [ __ ]
j'ai même pas le temps de lire ce que je
dois faire la ja au cube noir et des
petits points noirs et [ __ ] mais
[ __ ] toi dans ton cul merde et ce jeu
en plus il est moche mais [ __ ] c'est
horrible regardez ça la ville ne veut
rien dire
la ville ne veut rien dire il ya des
autoroutes qui rentre dans les immeubles
et qui s'arrêtent en plein milieu et de
toute façon on n'y voit rien car
regardez moi cette distance d'affichage
de merde mais c'est normal
les développeurs du jeu ils ont justifié
ça en dix ans c'est long mais son niveau
rien c'est parce que c'est un brouillard
de kryptonite
[Musique]
et si vous réussissez à franchir ce
genre de niveau n'ayez pas trop d'espoir
parce que ce qui suit c'est vraiment pas
mieux dans les niveaux normaux entre
guillemets tout ce que vous avez à faire
c'est airs et indéfiniment dans des
niveaux qui sont gigantesques et presque
intégralement vide à la recherche
d'objectifs qui sont complètement flou
et incompréhensible pendant que votre
superman lac est censé être invincible
et avoir des super pouvoirs
eh bien il se fera tuer comme une merde
par des randonneurs ennemis armés de
flèches et vous aurez pas de pouvoir
parce que vos pouvoirs il faut les
ramasser et vraiment pouvoir
là il ya des musiques de merde aussi
des musiques en quatre notes parce que
c'est que c'était trop demander en 4 9
parce que c'est moins cher à faire
composer en quatre notes ça suffit pour
bien te faire chier en quatre notes
oui ça s'enchaîne comme ça un genre de
cauchemar de ouf où tu joues un mec en
collant perdu dans un labyrinthe moche
avec aucun moyen de savoir où aller à me
tiens lettre du jeu et merci merci d
instruction captain obvious est
exactement ce qu a marqué au dos de la
boîte
heureusement pour se détendre entre deux
labyrinthes on retrouve nos amis les
cerceaux de borden pourquoi je bloque
tout le temps sur ces [ __ ] de murs et
torture ouais quoi
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui s'est passé
maintenant mais c'est pas vrai mais
pourquoi pourquoi ce jus mais pas depuis
tient aussi un serpent repassions les
anneaux de mer de la xe et déjà horrible
c'est si on faisait bouger les anneaux
ça serait plus drôle lol
[Musique]
vous vous souvenez pas drôle ça départ a
dû sans patins le meilleur détective du
monde superman l'homme d'acier
invincible et le meilleur jeu auquel
j'ai joué aujourd'hui c'est ça aquaman
vous savez ce que ça veut dire c'est
qu'on est mieux sous nos cieux et j'ai
compris ta souffrance maintenant c'est
évident que les yeux plein de super
héros ça m'a fait bien déprimé mais j'ai
découvert un endroit où je vais
m'éclater
fini les [ __ ] de cerceaux
j'avais vraiment plus qu'assez
maintenant je suis bien sous l'eau
laisse moi te l'expliquer sous l'océan
sous l'océan
comme jouer bien mieux à foreman fait
ah oui cependant le décrire ici le
gameplay c'est moins dur aux manettes on
fait la fête sous l'océan
[Musique]